hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday September 11th never forget
what's going on Hawaii
how are you
are you at your job
do you sit there and feel sad
why don't you get up and walk out
because you can't because the bankers
have you by the balls
it's kind of amazing
how money just makes you do [__] you
don't want to do
or the fear of not having it
or the amount of money you owe people
you know
be nice if you just be like a little kid
go over there and get in that cue I
don't wanna do it all right all right
okay you don't have to
[Laughter]
why doesn't whining work as an adult
um
anyway
here I am I am in Greece I've been in
Greece for the last couple of days of
doing the Acropolis tonight
and
um
then I go home and I get to see my
family and that's what I'm thinking
about
I won't be thinking about that when I'm
on stage tonight though because it's
going to be [__] amazing
but um
I'm not gonna lie to you that's what I
was thinking last night before I went to
bed I'm like this is my last [__] net
tomorrow night show and then I'm getting
on the plane I'm [__] going home
and it's been an absolutely incredible
trip over here
um
I was joking with the other comics
on the tour I go I feel like I won the
showcase showdown
on The Price is Right you know all these
cities
and all of this stuff
um
that I have seen
some of the Cities I'd been to before
others I haven't I can't remember
what uh show I had done the last time I
talked to you guys
but
I know I talked about Prague Berlin was
[__] amazing
amazing City it went went down to
Checkpoint Charlie
so what's left of the Berlin Wall
and um the city just has like a great
Vibe you know those refugees that come
in from around the world I guess you
know
Berlin Germany is a place where they
accept them
um
which is cool
helping out other people Greece does it
too you know
um
speaking of money isn't that [__] up a
bunch of refugees overcrowded on a
[__] boat and then they're out there
and they get in trouble and then
countries all they love gonna cost us
money to go out there and
try to help those you know give a [__]
about other things do you
always give a faith and we start talking
about money when it's helping goddamn
people but when it's you know [__]
rubbing the balls of some Corporation
they don't give a [__] what it does to
the right I swear to [__] God hey did
I call it
on that Robert F Kenny Jr [__] I knew
they were going to bury that guy I
[__] knew they were gonna bury that
guy I love
when you're a [__] politician and you
actually call out corporations for the
absolutely heartless
horrible [__] that they're doing to
people and then you immediately get
labeled a fringe
you know he's out on The Fringe which
you know just a little buzzword to make
it sound like you're [__] crazy
so here's my thing
if you don't like that guy I get it you
know there's other people like here's my
thing why isn't any other politician
talking about what the [__] he's talking
about
you know
a Democrat or Republican why aren't any
of them talking about how one
Corporation is trying to buy up all the
houses
in the United States to become the
landlord for everybody and literally
take away that part of the American
dream
just out of yourself so if you don't
like Robert F Kennedy and he's French
and all that why isn't any other
candidate talking about how one company
bought up all the [__] pig farms put
all these Farmers out of [__]
business turned them into surfs on their
own [__] land and then turned around
and sold it
to a company in China
all right okay you want to say the guys
on the [__] Fringe why are the rest
of them just going around saying nothing
you know why because they're already
bought and paid for every [__] one of
them every [__] one of these [__]
pieces of [__] and the genius is they
got everybody looking at the color of
ties oh I like those colors ties they
they share my values is that what your
[__] values are
drives me up the [__] wall even
though I knew it was coming it
disappoints me every [__] time
I mean our country is getting so [__]
corrupt like they can just openly do
this [__] yeah we're not counting the
delegates and [__]
and uh we're not whatever the [__] we're
not counting them in New Hampshire
that you mean
I don't know you tell me the difference
between this and the WWE if you could
tell me that I I I will [__]
high-five you
unbelievable
I'm [__] around well what are you
gonna do but other than that you know
something that's why I like traveling
because I will tell you this like the
people that I've met and just observed
sitting around like I didn't go to any
stupid ass [__] tourist attractions
tourist attractions are for [__] dumb
people and people in relationships
which a lot of times is the same person
right
that's what they're for you don't
[__] do that if you come over here
and you're by yourself just go [__]
sit in a cafe drink a cup of coffee
watch the [__] go by
talk to the locals don't go to the dumb
thing that everybody's going to have you
seen the Obelisk yeah I can see it from
here
I'm not going to stand down here with a
bunch of jerk-offs watching the changing
of the garden okay I get it right they
they they do their they they do their
[__]
little uh little show there they they
step this way they step that way
I'm not gonna sit 40 [__] deep in
obesity
I have a limited amount of [__] time
over here
all right
this is this is why you don't need to
see tourist attractions because if you
notice the people that live here are not
only are they walking by it they're not
even looking at it
you know
I moved to New York City do you know I
was there for [__] 12 years how many
times I went to the Statue of Liberty
once
I went there once because I somebody
came to town and they wanted to go and I
was [__] miserable
who the [__] goes on vacation to stand
in line
I'll stand in line after a hurricane
when I don't have any bread
[Laughter]
I'm not standing in line to look at some
[__]
oh you go in here we got uh [__] you
know
Henry Henry VII's robe oh my God you
gotta see it I don't I don't have to see
it I can go online I can look at a
[__] picture of it that's it's it's
no different than when somebody is
talking about some new TV series oh my
God you gotta see it
okay yeah it's you know
season four just happened
season four just dropped it's like wait
I'm Four Seasons behind three seasons
behind yeah forget it I'm not catching
up
I'm not catching you got it oh come on
are you acting so I'm sure it is I'm
sure it is but you know what sometimes
in life you just gotta accept the fact
that you missed it
I missed it and then just saved the
person just tell me what happened no I
don't want to ruin it you're not ruining
it
you're not really you are saving me 60
hours of my life
I'm sure it's great I'm sure the acting
is unfucking believable just [__]
tell me what happened
I did that with uh
succession
my wife was watching and everything and
you know the acting was amazing on it
and everything like that but like
it was depressing
[Music]
I don't see a bunch of loveless people
just [__] walking around going after
money and stabbing each other in the
[__] bed and like
I watched that show for three episodes
or whatever the [__] I did and once none
of the family members just killed their
dad or nobody just said you know what
[__] this family
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go learn how to
skateboarders just go enjoy life I don't
give a [__] keep your [__] money
it's so stupid
that oh keeps bringing me back to that
Arnold Schwarzenegger moment when he
goes out as a little man in such a big
desk
that is a little man needs such a big
immediately took all that guy's power
away I don't give a [__] about you and
your big desk
you want to put me in one of your movies
fine if you don't somebody else will I'm
gonna make it either way I'm not sitting
here waiting for you to tap your [__]
magic wand on my head and to tell me I
can live a [__] life now
ah
boat Billy's [__] grumpy today
oh grumpy bill
that's what he is so I'm in Greece now
Athens
right
and uh I'm not gonna lie to you I did
walk up to the Acropolis
what I liked about it was there was no
line he just walked around
it was a little line to buy like tickets
and stuff like that but I wanted to you
know check out the theater
which I thought the theater was the
Acropolis it isn't it's the theater at
the Acropolis
and um
we went up there you know we looked at
all of the stuff and they got all this
[__] roped off you know we're not
supposed to go in and some [__]
[__] goes in and takes a uh
takes a selfie oh my God one of the
dudes up there goes hey hey
let's get out of there he goes he goes
show some respect give me a camera
delete that photo the guy tried to do
another
the piece of [__] try to show him a
different photo
right
and that guy goes that's not the photo
he goes that's the one
show some respect and he [__] yelled
at him it was fantastic
it was [__] fantastic
um
and also that guy
that guy you know the Scarlet Letter
that guy should have a Scarlet Letter on
him
that he's that level of a selfish [__]
and that he's also that shallow that he
thought anybody on social media was
gonna give a [__] that he was three feet
closer to the [__] thing
you know than the rest of us
I don't know I've been learning some
[__] though out here
um Greek Greek coffee
so I ordered this Greek coffee it comes
in like the tiniest little glass uh so I
knew it was going to be strong and the
coffee grounds are at the bottom of it
so I'm sitting there going you know I'm
toughing and I'm going am I supposed to
drink all of this and they were like
laughing at me they go no you only drink
down to here you didn't look like half
it but it was really good but when I got
down to like the [__] coffee grinds I
felt like I was eating oysters when you
know except there was no oyster in there
you know when you get like the sand
um
but anyways the vibe here in Greece is
[__]
incredible
um
it's like you're the halfway point
it feels like half Italy half turkey
you know what I mean you got like
going in that going out towards Italy
Vibe and then you got going towards
turkey vibe
so the food is [__] incredible
and then there was so many uh
Street musicians
that were Arab and playing all their
type of music and everything man it was
[__] amazing
[__] amazing and it made me want to
keep going
eventually at some point in my life
keep going east
and you know kind of following that
music and those people and all of that
it's just really really cool vibe
um
and uh
yeah made me think of that drama Youssef
days because I think he's
I want to say he's part Turkish or
whatever and all the different
influences in his music and like sort of
hearing a little bit of that as I was
walking down the street it was really
incredible and I'll tell you Greece
Athens looked nothing like I thought it
was going to look like I don't my idea
was it was all those [__] islands
that they show where all the buildings
are white and there's people living
there Beth's lives you know
vacation I'm actually in the city where
people work and [__] and it is crowded
as hell this time of year and uh you
know what's funny is I was gonna rent a
scooter I always say I'm going to rent a
scooter I never get around to it I'm
like I gotta write a Vespa in [__]
Europe you know ciao America right you
know [__] do that [__] and uh
so club soda Kenny inquired about it and
two people immediately said don't do
that don't do that and I go the streets
are very dangerous to drive and I
wouldn't do that right
and um
so we land in Athens and driving
to the hotel
we see there's an accident some guy went
down on a bike and they were putting him
in the back of the ambulance he saw it
was all scraped up and bloody and all
that looked like he was going to be all
right
um
and I was like well there you go and
then we got into the City and it's
what's funny when you're in the
crosswalk they don't stop they slow down
and you definitely become really aware
of your legs it's the first thing you're
thinking about like that car is going to
[__] hit me right the side of my FEMA
um
but anyway it's just been really uh
you know amazing couple of protests out
here
um
I didn't know what they were talking
about or anything and one night the
first night we hung out
um in this park
you know reminded me of Washington
Square Park
or or like uh Union Square
in like 1995 in New York City it was
just like a bunch of young kids they had
their music going
uh kids who are playing soccer football
whatever the [__] they call it over here
um
and all just young people hanging out
socializing trying to figure themselves
out anything
and uh
we would just [__] hang we just post
it up over the corner just sort of took
it in man it was [__] amazing it was
really really amazing
um and before I got here
we were in Budapest
which
um
I think at the bet the best comedy
crowds
in Europe I mean they're just [__]
unbelievable
the unbelie anything goes they don't
give a [__] they [__] laugh at
everything and I play this great venue
uh it's the second time
I played it and uh you know last time I
was there
it's a winter time and I had a sore
throat or something like that and one of
the promoters moms got me was a nurse
and had gotten me some medicine and she
remembered and I came back and she had
left the note and gave me the same
medicine in case I was sick again it was
really [__] cool
uh
uh and before that we were in Stockholm
Sweden oh Budapest by the way I got some
of the best [__] coffee I'd ever had
um one of the guys over here that works
for Live Nation barang Bang Bang
one of my favorite people in the [__]
world he um
every place he goes he tries to find the
best of whatever he's doing you know
whatever restaurant
um coffee
whatever it is you're trying to do he
goes out
it's funny it's almost like you know the
two chain show that he had most
expensivist I was saying it's like dude
you need to host a show
like that except it rather than
expensive it's the best because
he's more geared towards the best rather
than
how much it costs which usually is one
in the same but
um he found this place to get coffee
when we were in um
Budapest by the way uh we did do another
touristy thing but only because there
was no line we went on the ferris wheel
at Budapest it was the smoothest running
thing anyway
ever and if you don't have time to see
the [__] City
um
when we saw this [__] we just you know I
walked we looked at it or whatever
but like I just I can't do the line
thing
you know
do you know when we were in Berlin
yeah we saw uh I don't know what it's
called but it's that
the the the bust like the head
a famous
sure your [__] still jet-like here
that famous [__] um
I don't know what you call it
piece of artwork it was like it's like
the Mona Lisa of Egypt
that the Germans stole when they were
[__] occupied
um
Northern Africa in World War II which is
just [__] amazing to me man like
somebody's telling me he goes dude
because you want to see some of the
biggest crimes ever go in the basement
of the Vatican
it's like they've stolen more goddamn
[__] there and and the reason that they
did it is beyond just greed because it's
worth something they wanted to steal
people's culture so they didn't know
you know of their accomplishments
so it could seem like the decide that
the Catholic church was on was this
event at more advanced smart people it
is the most evil [__] [__]
that's what kills me you know the pope
sits there
and gives all those speeches and saying
don't you think in 2023 at some point
they could give that [__] back
and be like look it was a long time ago
um
it was wrong
and we've now progressed and thought
that we understand how horrible this is
to do
to a different race or culture or
whatever so here is this stuff after
centuries
like what are they hanging on to it for
what are you going to sell at a [__]
yard sale
you're not doing anything with it it's a
bunch of clutter
maybe you could [__] get rid of it
you know put a workout room down there
maybe a home theater
instead of having just a bunch of
Priceless stuff that's not yours how do
you go up there and [__] say Mass
thou shall not steal and all of that
stuff that's you know you shall not
covet
you [__]
yeah
foreign
that they got a bunch of stolen goods
there on the other side too
like some [__] common Criminal
I need a fence man I gotta unload this
[__]
the heat is coming down on me man
um
anyway
what else what else did I do I did
Stockholm Sweden
did Stockholm Sweden I had a great time
there
uh highlight of that trip other than the
incredible crowd that showed up
I got to play this uh this Arena over
there
and um
it was all like red on the inside and
everything it kind of was giving me like
Royal Albert Hall type of vibes
um and the crowd was incredible but my
favorite part
um initially it was sad
because when I got there I was staying
right around the corner from the first
hotel
I stayed at like that's my like my fifth
time there
and there was a hotel that I stayed in
the first time
the burn hotel if it's to burn something
or other I stayed there with the lovely
Nia
and you know
God that was like 2009 I think
and um
you know it was such a fun trip because
me has always wanted to you know since
she was a little girl wanted to travel
and everything and getting to do that
with her and seeing how excited she was
with every country that we were going to
and
her trying to like
you know
check stuff out so first I saw that that
was sad
um
but then I kind of walked around
found some beautiful parks
and stuff
um you know just walking around I
literally didn't go in anywhere
remember a long time ago I looked at
that big ship that had sunk that they
raised up but I was also staying there
for like five days or something
um
but I ended up sort of finding this uh
this coffee shop that I went into and
the guy in there was Italian
and there's a few Italian people in
there so you're speaking Italian to them
and then he was speaking
um
uh Swedish to the regulars and then he
spoke English to me
I was like Jesus Christ these [__]
people over here
how much room is in their brain
um
so anyway I uh
I missed all the NFL football
shout out to Paul verzi calling the
Lions against the Chiefs
uh I have no idea I don't even know if
my Pat's won I heard that they were
giving him a good game though
let's look it up here
let's go to the [__] ticker
um where are we here
let's see Pat's
Patriots
oh they lose a heartbreaker 25-5 and and
the Eagles covered
the Eagles cup
and I stayed away from that game I was
thinking about it oh I was thinking
about it
and I was going to take the Eagles
because I think the Patriots are
actually going to have a good season but
I also feel like it's one of those deals
where
[Music]
um
you know you're not just going to come
out of the gate
way better than you were last year I
think we're going to start a little slow
but I think by uh the end of October
beginning in November people are not
going to want to play us that's what I'm
hoping is going to happen
um but we shall see oh tonight is
um
the [__] uh
Jets versus the bills I believe and I
can't [__] get any football over here
I know it's on YouTube and all I gotta
do is just [__] sign up
I just haven't gotten around to doing it
I gotta be honest with you too the
[__] NFL really annoys me
well they go yeah you can be on YouTube
You're Gonna you don't have to stick
some dish on the side of your house it's
like well you didn't [__] say that
you know 15 years ago when you went to
DirecTV
why the [__] would you say that and you
don't have to stick some dish on the
side of the house like do you think I'm
so dumb that I don't remember that you
already did that
you didn't [__] give a [__] 15 years
ago
um
here's one for you how long do you think
the NFL is going to ignore that study
that they did over in Europe you know
those fields that they have where they
have the recycled tires there those
recycled tires have lead in them and
they're finding that they have this high
level higher than normal level of cancer
with uh football players in Europe
meaning soccer to fellow Americans and
specifically the goalkeeper who you know
Dives around on it so now they're
they're making that illegal over there
and you [__] watch
how long it takes them to get rid of
that [__] over over yeah here in America
you [__] watch because all the
corporate [__] have infiltrated any
sort of watch group
in our government they just were like
what is the group that is is watching us
making our lives miserable let's get one
of our guys in there and they will
approve everything oh Bill you're
bringing the [__] rain clouds today I
am
I am bringing that because every [__]
four years I just watch and it's
specifically lately it's been the
goddamn Democratic party the [__]
Democrats the bleeding heart liberals
yeah we know you [__] wanted Bernie
Sanders but go [__] yourself
go [__] yourself you're getting Hillary
Clinton oh we know you wanted Bernie
again go [__] yourself you're getting
this guy with dementia
oh we know this guy Robert
you know
F Kennedy Jr he's you know we know he's
going to do well and uh yeah go [__]
yourself but we're liberal and we
believe in democracy
and by the way [__] all you Democrats
who are going to go who's the guy can't
win it's a wasted vote you're a wasted
vote you're a wasted vote because you
keep voting for these [__] corrupt
pieces of [__]
and then you got the convenient out of
blaming the other colored tie and
they're the reason for all the [__]
problems it's like the God complex
that's not a God complex it's like God
has the convenience of the devil
God created the devil so he would have a
[__] excuse when he made a serial
killer
I 100 percent believe that that's
[__] stupid God gave his freedom a
choice he get he doesn't give you
Freedom a choice when he makes your
[__] mentally ill and you're going
around eating other human beings there's
something [__] wrong with you
from the day you're born there's
something [__] wrong with you coming
out of the [__] Barn
right [__] mad dog Mad Dog and he
gets ah was the devil
nah dude it was you
it was you
um
all right well
I don't I don't have any of my [__]
advertising so I I don't really know
what I'm supposed to talk about here I
will tell you this I found this a movie
I want to see
um there's a town I know where the
hipsters go called bedrock twist twist I
don't know why I'll never get that song
out of my [__] head
um hang on a second where is it I took a
picture of it why does it do that what
is this
like how I blame the phone when I just
did that
you know when you're scrolling through
your photos and then it just it [__] it
just [__] did it again [__] this
[__] goddamn phone why can't you
[__] scroll through the phone the
[__] pictures anymore
it then turns them into days I don't
remember what [__] day it was on
Jesus Christ
these [__] goddamn phones I swear to
God I can't [__] do anything on them
but the amount of [__] I can
accidentally do is is astounding
I can't close a [__] window until I'm
trying to film something right and then
my phone like slips in my hand a little
bit and somehow like the [__] meat
below my pinky finger slams right down
on the X and stops [__] recording or
hits a stop button whatever it is
whatever people I've just been on tour
too long I'm in a bad [__] mood I'm
gonna be in a great mood tonight when I
go out there I've been joking around
with the wager waiters and waitresses
here kind of a little hit or miss not
gonna lie to you so I'm thinking that
it's gonna be
um the vibe's gonna be more like
Stockholm than Budapest which are we're
both amazing crowds but two completely
different like rhythms
um
where Budapest I can be more like an
American mode and then
Stockholm like Helsinki places like that
like their uh
they're super [__] polite so they
laugh and then they want to shut up
because they want to hear what you're
going to say next and they don't want to
be rude
it's really amazing it's like it's just
looking at them like they still make
people like you I didn't know they made
people this [__] polite
it's incredible have I mentioned by the
way how windy it's been
here in uh Athens which really I gotta
be honest with you in a lot of ways
reminds me of Los Angeles
it has like an LA Vibe where there's
just like so many [__] people here
that like
you know the Mediterranean Sea we were
seeing was like eight miles away but
it's a 40-minute drive
you know and we all live in Los Angeles
so like oh oh it's one of those there
was actually so many made a [__]
hilarious video
about living in LA and when people come
to visit
like how they just don't understand
you know how long it takes to get
somewhere in Los Angeles
and they'll just be like yeah I figured
we'd go to like the Griffith Park
Observer Observatory and then we'd head
over to Malibu and hit the beach and
it's just what wait what
foreign
you think we're doing that in one
[__] day
either one of those things is going to
be all [__] those things are separate
days
and they might have to be a day in
between of them because you don't want
to [__] sit in traffic again
um I kind of feel like uh
like Greece is like that but uh
I don't know I'm gonna walk the streets
today because I saw a couple of drummers
and I'm hoping I'm gonna see some more
with that uh
the whole Middle Eastern Vibe turkey
Armenia all of that all of that good
[__]
they got those symbols that sound
[__] amazing and uh and then they
just playing these rhythms that you know
I've only heard a little bit living out
in the west man it's [__] cool as
[__]
um
all right I don't know what else I can
talk about here
because uh
I don't I don't have my advertising and
then I also don't have the uh
the questions here
answer the question oh by the way I
missed the whole U.S open
um I did see the clip that woman won her
first uh
uh major or whatever man [__] Sports
is just the best
you know what I mean I don't know I
understand why I guess they
people watch like reality shows and just
watch those fights and all of that dumb
[__] but like if you just want to see
like genuine emotion that's not assisted
reality
just like watching how [__]
like happy and overwhelmed can you
imagine that winning a major
especially tennis too that is such a
brutal brutal [__] game
um
some of those men's matches go like five
[__] hours you play five hours
running around
start and stopping in the [__] Sun
you lose a five set Heartbreaker
and you just gotta go [__] lay down
in your hotel room bed thinking about
that [__] and shaking it off and
continuing on the tour like the level of
how tough you have to be mentally
you know
they're always talking about golf how
[__] tough you have to be mentally
golf get the [__] out of here
walking up to your ball
looking around yeah that's it man you
know you just have to it's all that
thinking it's just like
I swear to God
reminds me of some of the [__] you hear
like [__] I can't I'm not gonna go
down that road
come on Bill you took the mushrooms you
let go of some of that [__]
um
anyway what the [__] was I just going to
talk about
oh I know
like uh
oh that Deion Sanders stuff how great is
it that he won like that that first game
and everything you know and everybody
you know a lot of people not everybody
I know that they got to bring up the
racist [__] but I also want to say
to Dion that me and all of my friends
are white guys in our 50s and all we're
doing is sharing
all these speeches that you're making
and everything we think it's [__]
great so we're not all bad
but I also have to know that the guy
does have a point when he's saying that
they don't like it because he's a black
guy
him being all confident and all this
[__] it's 100 [__] it's a hundred
percent [__] true because you tell me
what is the difference between
the stuff he's saying and what Rex Ryan
said
when he was coaching the Jets the
[__] media loved Rex Ryan
they love a guy like that that's just
gonna say what he's thinking and give
him all these great quotes like a coach
like that a head coach like that
just literally writes the article for
him they have an easy day talking to
that guy
so like why when Dion does it is it now
with a [__] problem what is what is
the difference
which by the way is why Sports writers
[__] hate Bill Belichick because he
knows what they're doing it's like I'm
not going to give you some bulletin
board material I'm not saying [__]
it's like hey coach Belichick you're
playing the worst [__] team in the
history of football next week
uh you think you're gonna have a nice
easy win he's like
uh you know it's it's a game just like
any other game and uh we're gonna
approach it that way and uh that's what
we always do and that's what we plan on
doing
and then the sports writers are like
[__] man
I [__] fight lives out of that
I was hoping you were going to agree
with what I said so then I could do an
easy article saying Bill Belichick does
not respect the blah blah blah
um
anyways Alabama the dream ended early
this year
but for some reason with college
football it's not about the amount of
losses you have it's about when you lose
so
um
I always crack up whenever whenever
Alabama loses I always picture Mrs Saban
just [__]
going off to their vacation house
just like
honey I don't want to be around this
okay I don't want to be you know you're
going to turn the season around you're
Alabama you're [__] Nick Saban I'm
not gonna be sitting here as you're
shooting me looks like I dropped that
pass in the flat all right just enough
okay I I do support you I do support you
but at some point I have to choose
myself
um
oh my God
I cannot wait
to get home to see my kids I cannot wait
I've been FaceTiming with them and
everything but it's it's uh
it's just not the same
I am coming home and I am [__]
dropping my bags and getting down on the
floor and [__] wrestling with them
for like 40 to 45 minutes
and then I'm gonna unpack I cannot wait
to see him
um oh Billy French face is getting back
into his French again after taking like
you know a leisurely six month my brain
just got tired I got frustrated and now
I'm finding with this Pimsleur that you
don't necessarily have to do like the
the
lessons
you know if your brain gets tired of
that you get overwhelmed you've gotten
too much information in them if you just
do like the practice things and turn
them into like flash cards you can get
it going again and then you can listen
to people talk I also been listening to
the radio
um
it's been another good thing about
traveling and all these people not
speaking a language that I speak that I
understand is you get really good at
reading body language
and uh
which of course Nia could do right out
of the gate
she just [__]
um I remember we one time we went France
we were ordering in French
and uh I ordered a steak and I was so
proud of myself I did I said hello to
the guy I said what I wanted to drink
and I ordered a steak all in French
and then he said something to me and I
didn't know what it
meant you know the waiter was having fun
with us because he appreciated that we
were trying to learn the language right
and I didn't know what he said after I
ordered the steak and the of course
immediately goes did you ask him how he
wants it cooked
and he was like
I'm like of course that's what the [__]
he asked me but I'm so busy like [__]
trying to like
in like a one-dimensional way understand
this guy which is listen to what he's
saying and try and pick out some words
you know
Nia who's like a total like Vibes person
who by the way has the greatest Vibe of
anybody I've ever met
um
she like
she on she can like try to understand on
three levels at the same time
she was listening to what he was saying
was thinking well what usually comes
next and then was also watching his body
language
and uh
yeah
it's it's actually [__] annoying how
good she is
[Laughter]
um
all right I gotta get some breakfast
here uh I am gonna see if I can I for
some reason I'm not getting the
questions or anything like that this
might be a short podcast
this week a little Monday Morning
podcast slider which by the way
um if you haven't checked it out yet we
put out the uh
um
Bill Burr live at the Troubadour part
three troubadour
um
and I'm really really proud of it we did
a great job Andrew demolis
The Greek Freak did a great job did like
a three camera shoot or something like
that and people have been saying it's as
funny as any of my stand-up specials
it's totally for free it is a podcast I
know it kind of looks like I'm doing
stand up I was just
doing what I'm doing right now but I was
just walking around there was a crowd to
feed off of and uh it kind of came off
like I was doing stand up but it is a
podcast that's you know
um not me doing stand up it's just a
podcast but it kind of comes off like
that which I'm very happy with
um and a lot of people are trashing the
crowd the crowd is not miked all right
there's no way I could do an hour and 50
something minutes in front of a crowd
that wasn't giving it up and then also
people's you know idea
of like La crowds
um
yeah you got to go out to LA it just
you go into Hollywood
it's gonna be super liberal but once I
say this all the time once you get out
of it it isn't
it's like uh this
it gets pretty hardcore to the right
pretty goddamn fast so
um
oh by the way oh I forgot this one night
I was hanging out
was me Kenny and Bianca and we were
hanging out and we were at the hotel
and there was a bunch of Americans there
they were at a wedding and they had a
Greek themed wedding so they were all
walking around looking like [__]
you know Emperors and [__] or whatever
like they were wearing the white
[__] onesie with the leaves you know
that go around your head you know
and
Bianca was like rolling her eyes going
oh my God why the [__] would you do that
blah blah blah and I'm going that's not
like cultural appropriation I mean
they're all like
it's white people it's Greek people like
what are we doing here and I wasn't
hearing what she was saying she was
saying it's like going to like [__]
like they're turning a wedding to like
Disneyland or whatever and I was
defending these [__] people
and then they started and then
because we'd seen him in the hotel right
but then
like when we were like late at night
when the wedding was happening where we
were like hanging out
you know I was having a coffee they were
having a you know glass of wine or
something
um people started walking in and out
and oh my god I've never been so wrong
for so [__] long
just
I can't even explain it man this one
woman walked by and she talked was
talking to her friend she goes what can
I say I'm a good time
[Music]
oh what can I say we're a good time
and then I saw her husband at some point
and he had done the Greek theme thing
but he wore a Hawaiian shirt instead
just to let him know that you know
the the you know the we still know how
to party we might be older but we still
know how to party oh it was really bad
it was [__] bad and I died on that
Hill man I defended that party for the
better part of a [__] hour and then
the last three hours we were hanging out
because people were getting drunker and
louder and they just kept walking by and
it was just one [__]
[__] show
after another and uh
I don't know just it was I don't know it
was a fun night I'm sure everybody there
had like a good time
I don't even remember the point I was
trying to make
um about it like they can do that if
they want to do it whatever they're
having fun and then afterwards I was
like nah nah
it was like an episode of The Office
and everyone was Steve Carell
just completely like [__] clueless
man it was really funny but uh
yeah I met so many cool people I met
these uh these people from Arizona
oh I didn't tell you this oh this is the
best
I was hanging out right smoking a cigar
after I told you guys
I quit them for the umpteenth town but
I'll when I get back to the States oh
Jesus bill
um I'm gonna put them down for a while
uh
so I was hanging out
and I was watching uh the World Cup of
basketball
and I think it was Germany versus
Slovakia
I think I'm not sure and I saw a couple
of NBA players you know current NBA
players playing in it Germany won it was
a [__] great game
and uh
we're in there
and there's this guy where English is
his second language as he's talking
about I guess the team he wanted to win
wasn't winning and he was bitching about
the guy makes a hundred million euros
like just
instead of saying dollars so that was
already cool listening to damn bitching
about how many [__] Euros somebody
was making but at one point it was funny
he was by himself and there was like a
four top next to him
and
um for all of them
they all spoke a different language but
English was the common language and the
broken English that was coming up was
[__] hilarious
that guy was bitching about how many
euros people were making I swear to God
somebody asked him what he did for a
living and he goes me I work in a
computer
[Applause]
I work in a computer he almost had it I
work in computers he almost had it
but he said I work in a computer and
I've been [__] I was laughing about
that for like a [__] hour
um the most miserable possibly the most
miserable job you could have on the
planet would be to work in a computer me
I work in a computer and he was saying
because you could tell he was proud of
his job
um
I don't know maybe it was one of those
things he had to be there but that that
and the German guy the guy in Berlin
Well my two favorite interactions
where
you know where's the bathroom oh Seth is
easy you see the marble staircase you go
down and you're already there
foreign
[Music]
you go down this thousand and you are
already there
that is I don't know what it is but it's
so [__] silly
that you're already there
I'm that's I'm gonna I'm gonna [__]
be doing that
with Nia and it's gonna make her laugh
because she loves silly jokes but then I
love making her laugh so I'll keep
[__] doing it and then it's gonna
start to annoy her and she's gonna be
like all right you need to stop doing
that and then that'll be the next level
of the comedy because now I know that
it's [__] annoying her
and uh and those are the things that I
miss so anyway oh we got to fly in and
um oh Billy [__] jumper seat I got
this sit up front
and watch these guys do a landing they
had the Garmin 5 000.
and uh
you know I was just watching them
I was psyched I knew exactly what was
going on as far as like
their instrument plan I still remember
that and flying to the fixes and then
all of a sudden they divert as we get
near the airport and I'm like okay
there's got to be somebody bigger and
faster coming in so now they want the
they want us behind them they're
vectoring us around we get back to the
the you know
whatever the [__] you call it the flight
path to land and um
I was just seeing like it was fun to be
up there to see the speed that they have
to land at
um
it was a little jet that we landed in
and I was really it's like it was right
around 125 knots they landed at
and then I was really impressed with how
quickly they could stop it it's not like
those big [__]
you know like a fat guy running down the
hill that's what's like trying to stop a
[__] jumbo jet the smaller ones
it's really uh
they can pretty it like I don't know I
was impressed I thought we'd have to use
like three quarters of the runway the
guy like Barely Used a third of it and
just [__] banged the left we were
like right off of it but
um
just being able to like read those
screens and all of that stuff and then
like when they were taken off I was
sitting up there too and uh
just like their their
how fast that [__] thing can climb
they were saying on a cold day it could
do as as well as upwards of seven
thousand feet per minute I mean that's
just [__]
me in a little helicopter I'm psyched if
I can get like 600 feet per minute
[__] guys just
you know what anybody out there listen
and fly one of them fighter jets one of
them they rap fighter jets I would love
to know
um
what your climb rate is because I've
seen that I've gone just you know been
to a comedian we always
do shows for troops and stuff and then
they give us these amazing tours and
stuff I've been to
um I think I went to one in Arizona
Arizona coming up again and I watched
this guy
take off in a fighter jet and he's
taking it off and it looks normal and
they just pulls back on the stick and
just goes straight up
and just disappeared
I mean it looked like he was flying like
seven thousand feet a second
um
like that Chuck Yeager stuff so if
anybody out there flies for the military
what is the climb rate of one of those
fighter jets
it's so UNF it's so unbelievable
that they have dog fights and those
things
and literally that I I believe those
Jets can like
can do things that the human body can't
even take which is crazy to me because
I've heard stories of guys doing stuff
like you know they they try to hold they
do that that breathing thing where they
try to hold their
you know self really tight so that and
the suit squeezes so the blood doesn't
go to their extremities like you know it
goes down to their feet
and they just pass out there's been
stories of Fighters uh fighter pilots in
dog fights
passing out from the G's and then waking
up a few seconds later and they shook
the guy so they don't die and then
they're like oh [__] I'm flying a plane
and somebody's trying to kill me like
how do you get back into that
like coming up off the couch never just
fall asleep you're like watching TV and
then you're starting to come around and
you forget what day it is or where
you're at
especially if you do the road like in my
home right now or am I in [__] Des
Moines you know and then
it's like that feeling but you wake back
up in a dog fight you're in an airplane
and somebody's trying to shoot you out
of the [__] sky
is incredible
um
anyway I will be telling you guys about
um my show first stand-up show that
they've ever done at the theater at the
Acropolis in Athens Greece I cannot
[__] believe to be honest with you
I've been really downplaying this
that
um
that I'm going to get to do this uh
yeah it's just another one of those
things that I didn't
I you know this was never on the radar
of something that I ever would think was
possible so thank you before the show
uh beforehand here to everybody
in in Greece that is coming out to this
show it's going to be [__] amazing I
can already feel it I know
um
yeah it's gonna be a magical night
um all right that's it that is the
podcast I gave you 54 minutes here all
right cut me some slack with the last
six minutes I will talk to you guys
later actually you know what at some
point Andrew's gonna send me the read so
it'll get up to an hour so they go
there's your [__] podcast it wasn't a
slider
all right
it was a main course there
um that's it go [__] yourselves and I
gotta sign up
for the NFL on YouTube now that I've
made fun of them for the nine millionth
time all right I'll check in on you on
Thursday